it's not Republican it's not Democrat
honestly it's not liberal it's not
conservative it's not left with its
economic if you tax people who work and
you pay people who don't work don't be
surprised if you get a lot of people not
working hi i'm tim cavanaugh a recent TV
we're here at the Orange County Register
offices with the legendary Arthur Laffer
the founder of supply-side economics the
namesake of the Laffer curve and most
recently the author of Eureka how to fix
California doctor laugher thank you very
much for joining us my pleasure thank
you very much Jim what's the one
takeaway we need to do to fix California
well it's common sense I mean you know
you can't tax a state into prosperity I
know that sounds radical here but you
can't you need a low rate flat tax you
need all sorts of other reforms that
this goes through on water you need
reforms on electricity you need reforms
unelected officials I mean my one of my
suggestions would be you probably should
have merit pay for politicians and put
them on commission they should have skin
in the game when they do all this voting
they don't bear the consequences of
their own actions and it should be a
right-to-work state I mean right-to-work
states way outperformed on right-to-work
states and welfare I mean all of these
things should be done because it all
honestly the best form of welfare it's
still a good high paying job and it
really is if you would surprise people
the degree to which unions have sort of
captured California politics anything
yeah it's amazing describe that a little
well I'll give you one example I mean
California classroom teachers are the
highest paid in the nation and they are
I mean the year I do it in that book as
a New Jersey's number two about 400
dollars higher than New Jersey and
they're the number one and yet the
Department of Education test scores for
fourth grade in eighth grade and math in
it and English California is the second
lowest state in the nation I mean which
really irritated me frankly because
after spending all that money in the
classroom teachers they should at least
have been able to beat Louisiana and be
the lowest in the nation but they
couldn't even do that but this is the
problem every single teacher in
California cares about his or her
students they really do they're
wonderful it's the system that does
allow that to manifest itself it's
tragic you do a lot of the failure the
familiar comparison of California with
Texas which are similar in size
demographics type of economy and so
forth what are the key differences
well it's tax structure it's all sorts
of spending structure it's the type of
government I mean they have a part-time
government we don't but I mean I
compared California with Texas
I do Tennessee with Kentucky you look at
New Hampshire versus Vermont you look at
all of these Florida versus New York but
I also get all of the repository of data
over the last 50 60 years of 50 states I
mean virtually everything that can be
done has been done and what I try to do
is is a straightforward clear way look
at how the results have been I mean what
happened when states lower their income
tax rates what happens when they raise
them I mean we had 11 states put in the
income tax in the last 50 years what's
been the result well all those states
are worse off today than they were when
they put in the income tax we really
it's terrible the income tax is very
extremely progressive it's really
present in the nation these thing about
and trying to make it more progressive
right I think in his heart Jerry Brown
has to know that that leads to more
volatility in collections totally he
knows that totally he's an extremely
smart man who is really well focused and
well oriented towards what incentives do
if you tax people who work and you pay
people who don't work don't be surprised
if you get a lot of people not working
right and that's just what California
has done is driven people out of the
state I think Jerry bonds great and I
think Jerry Brown has the potential
inside him to do the right thing and he
knows what the right thing is to do that
low rate flat tax the unions are a real
problem he knows that he knows you can't
live on unfunded liabilities the retired
policemen firemen nurses prison guards
olive come on who doesn't know that when
we talk about sort of Laffer curve type
of issue where you know a tax increase
will actually lead to flat or even lower
revenue raised how does how does that
work out practically is it that the rich
figure out maybe they hire more
accountants and figure out more ways to
make their income disappear if you saw
my piece in The Wall Street Journal on
Warren Buffett just a couple weeks ago
yeah of course he has all of his wealth
and unrealized capital gains
what's the tax right now an unrealized
capital gains zero if he gives it all to
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
and Sons Foundation as daughter's
foundation
it'll never see a tax that's not what we
want people to do we want people to pay
their taxes fair and square and not
worry about the tax dodgers loopholes
and all that no he's perfectly legal
what he does but it's wrong he should
pay his fair share if you calculate
Warren Buffett's income correctly in
2010 he paid 6/100 of 1% in taxes 7
million dollars was his total tax bill
for a total increase in wealth and spent
gifts of eleven and a half billion
dollars tell me about that you know
Ronald Reagan certainly gets all of the
credit as the supply-side president so
forth he deserves it and yet with John F
Kennedy in some ways that are forgotten
by history was actually an early avatar
told ID totally the Kennedys have always
been the most positive except for Teddy
were the most positive pro-growth
supply-side presidents and politicians
ever I mean Joe Kennedy as a congressman
was phenomenally good but Bobby Kennedy
his proposals before he was shot
we're perfect they were all of reagan's
proposals Jack Kennedy really created
the phenomenal growth of the sixties
thing the go-go sixties before he was
shy and Bill Clinton was a damn good
president too if I may say so I mean he
pushed me after through Congress against
his own party in the unions got rid of
the retirement tests and Social Security
signed into law welfare reform
reappointed Reagan's Fed Chairman twice
cut government spending as a share of
GDP by the largest amount of any
president and ever and and had the
biggest capital gains tax rate reduction
now he did it in partnership with Newt
Gingrich and the Republicans in the
house but you know the president's
deserve credit for that he does now so
far you've praised Jerry Brown the
Kennedys and Bill Clinton and yet you're
still publishing The Wall Street Journal
it's how does that well they did too by
the way I mean they I'm not the only one
but I've also praised Ronald Reagan
pretty much Bob Taft Hardy and Coolidge
I you know everyone thinks that and the
Republicans have been bad in some ones
Bob Dole voted against cutting the
highest tax rate from ninety-one percent
to seventy because we couldn't afford
the revenue losses Barry Goldwater led
all the Republicans to oppose Kennedy's
tax rate cuts on corporations from 52 to
46 percent
they forced him to compromise at 48
percent yikes so it's not Republican
it's not Democrat honestly it's not
liberal that's my conservative it's not
lessening its economic it's straight
forward common sense incentive economic
this is Arthur Laffer do you know you
don't interrupt this man but he's
talking all the way you know